ALAN SEALES: Please
welcome Benjamin Scheuer.
[APPLAUSE, CHEERS]
The show, my gosh,
I saw it last week.
It was absolutely amazing.
It was like this
unexpected journey
that I didn't expect to go on.
I didn't have any
expectations going into it.
But it's extremely personal.
Extremely, I guess, exposed,
for lack of anything else.
Because you talk about
some very serious things,
like happy and sad.
But actually, happy and
sad is very obvious, yes.
But I actually want
to read something
from the website about the show.
It says a good storyteller
uses everything he has.
So Benjamin Scheuer uses his
guitar, actually six guitars,
in "The Lion," a wholly original
downtown musical experience
that tells one man's
gripping coming-of-age story.
The award-winning songwriter
inspires and disarms
with his raw wit,
emotional depth,
and leads you on a rock-and-roll
journey from boyhood
to manhood through pain
and healing to discover
the redemptive power of music.
And that says it better
than obviously I ever could.
But would you mind
playing us a little song
to get us started, the
beginning of the show?
BENJAMIN SCHEUER: Sure.
Yeah.
This is how the show starts.
There's no introduction.
My father has an old guitar
and he plays me folk songs.
[MUSIC BENJAMIN SCHEUER, "COOKIE
TIN BANJO"]
[APPLAUSE]
ALAN SEALES: So how
old were you when you
did get that cookie-tin banjo?
BENJAMIN SCHEUER:
About 2, 2 and 1/2.
ALAN SEALES: Really?
That young?
BENJAMIN SCHEUER: Yeah.
I found a photo of
it recently, of me
playing my cookie-tin banjo.
It's pretty cool.
ALAN SEALES: Really.
[LAUGHTER]
BENJAMIN SCHEUER: I was
so excited to have it.
ALAN SEALES: So, um,
I mean you really
learned-- that's all- like
everything in the show
is a true story, right?
BENJAMIN SCHEUER: It's a true
story, it's all a true story.
ALAN SEALES: And so I'm going
to kind of give a synopsis here.
So you learned to
play instruments
from your dad growing up, the
relationship with your father.
I mean you're a
complete open book.
So I'm sharing this
with the world.
BENJAMIN SCHEUER: Oh, yeah.
Absolutely.
ALAN SEALES: The
relationship with your dad
doesn't go so well.
He dies young.
BENJAMIN SCHEUER: Yeah.
We get into a big
fight when I was 13.
And then sort of--
before we had reconciled,
a couple days later, he died
suddenly of a brain aneurysm.
And I totally blamed
myself as a kid.
I thought, oh, I
stressed my father out.
And then he died.
It's completely my fault.
Which is kind of
what you think when
you're 13 because the world
revolves around you when you're
13.
[LAUGHTER]
ALAN SEALES: Right.
So the song, I'm talking
about like the lyrics,
it's not-- what I like
about your song so much is
that it's not the traditional
kind of pop song lyrics.
Everything that comes out of
your mouth is telling a story.
Like you go somewhere with
everything that you sing about.
BENJAMIN SCHEUER:
Well, storytelling,
at least in theater,
is something
that I find really,
really fascinating.
And the thing about
storytelling in musical theater
is if you tell a song that
stops the action completely,
the audience is going
to be really bored.
Your songs need
to be the action.
They need to move the
story from point A
to point B. And
so one of the ways
to do that is to put something
in the present tense.
Don't put it in the past tense.
I could have said my
father had an old guitar
and he played me folk songs.
But audiences are smart.
And they know if I say, my
father has an old guitar
and he plays me folk songs, and
I'm singing as a 10-year-old,
they get it, as a two-year-old,
as a five-year-old.
People are smart.
And in musical theater--
so this song is very much
a musical theater song in
the guise of a folk song
inasmuch as the first song
in any piece of theater
in a musical is,
"this is our world."
Like in "The Lion King,"
it's the "Circle of Life."
And this is the world we're in.
We're in Africa.
There's lions.
There's elephants.
Great.
OK.
And then usually the
second song in a show
is the main character's
"I want song."
"I Just Can't Wait to be King."
Or in "The Little
Mermaid," I want
to be where the people are.
She says, "I want" in the
first line of the song.
And so the first line
of "Cookie-tin Banjo"
is my father has an old guitar
and he plays me folk songs.
OK.
So there's a kid and his
dad, guitars, and folk music.
Great.
That's our world.
First line, done, check.
Easy.
And the second line
is what's usually
the second song in a musical.
It's the main character's
"I want song."
There is nothing I want
more than to play like him.
OK, cool.
So little Ben wants
to play like Dad.
Off we go.
And so I don't like
to waste words.
Everybody's time is valuable.
And so, yeah, each song
is very much a story.
And I try to get
to things quick.
ALAN SEALES: Right.
So you were playing-- like
I thought from the show,
that you started it later.
But you're saying that you
started when you were two.
So like 2 to 13 is a long time.
So you played with your
father for-- like how often?
BENJAMIN SCHEUER:
Yeah, 10 years.
ALAN SEALES: And
your brothers too.
Like, all of you played?
BENJAMIN SCHEUER: Yeah.
I've two younger
brothers, Adam and Simon.
And Adam played the drums.
And Simon, who's 5 and
1/2 years younger than me,
just kind of played
whatever we let him
because he was so little.
ALAN SEALES: Played the blocks.
BENJAMIN SCHEUER: Yeah.
Now he's a killing songwriter,
writing songs professionally.
But my dad played the bass
and played the guitar.
And Simon would also
kind of play the piano
and play the guitar.
And we'd all play
music together.
And that's the way that
my father and I got along.
Because otherwise we'd
didn't get along so great.
Because he was super academic.
He went to Harvard and then
Columbia Law School, really,
really bright.
And all I ever wanted
to do was play music.
But I kind of sucked
at everything else.
ALAN SEALES: Because
he knew maths.
BENJAMIN SCHEUER: He
was very good at maths.
Which they call math in England.
ALAN SEALES: Because
your mother's British.
BENJAMIN SCHEUER: Yeah.
Mom grew up in London and
Dad grew up in New York.
And Mom moved to New York
when she was in her 20s.
And she and my father met.
And then when my father
died, when I was 13,
my mother moved our
family back to England.
And I went to an all-boys
boarding school, where
I studied music and English.
But they made me study math,
which I really sucked at.
And I was a pretty
angry teenager.
I was frustrated with my mom
for being sad all the time.
That was really nice
of me, wasn't it?
ALAN SEALES: It's
nice to throw blame.
BENJAMIN SCHEUER: Yeah.
Absolutely.
And I felt this
responsibility that I
had to look after my
two little brothers.
But I had no idea how I
was supposed to do that.
I was just a kid.
And so I got back to New York as
soon as I finished high school,
sort of as quick as possible.
And was playing gigs.
Actually, I had a residency
right around here.
There's was this club on
14th Street, between Eighth
and Ninth, called Rare.
It was a short-lived,
really awful place.
And I played there with my
rock-and-roll band sort of once
a week.
And it was great fun.
But then I met a
girl, which was nice.
And she kind of took
me from feeling sad,
to feeling a little understood.
And her name was Julia.
ALAN SEALES: Is this
leading into a song here?
BENJAMIN SCHEUER: I'm going
to lead into a song, yeah.
See how I did that?
And Julia and I had a great
relationship until we didn't.
And then we stayed together
for 6 and 1/2 years.
And eventually she told me
that she-- well, her parents
had an affair.
Her mother had an affair.
And so Julia started to see
sex as something shameful that
ruins relationships.
And so we had sex less and less.
And I asked her
what is going on?
And she didn't want to talk
about it because she didn't
want to betray her mother.
So Julia and I
talked less and less.
And I started to feel ill.
And I was losing weight and
sweating through my sheets.
And the left side of my lower
back hurt when I drank alcohol.
And then Julia told
me she wants to go
on a trip around the world
by herself, without me.
And we don't
mention breaking up.
And I tell her
I'll wait for you.
I'll be lonely when you go.
And she says, Ben, you're
the loneliest person I know.
Even if I stay,
you'll be lonely.
I said where exactly are
you planning on going?
[MUSIC BENJAMIN SCHEUER,
"INVISIBLE CITIES"]
And off she goes.
And I really love her.
And things have gotten so
bad between the two of us
that if what she needs
is to figure herself out,
away from me, then that's
what she should do.
I don't hear from
her for a long time.
And then I get an email.
[MUSIC BENJAMIN SCHEUER,
"INVISIBLE CITIES"]
So Julia never comes home.
And that song came out of
my trying to understand why.
And so I wrote it
from her perspective.
And I find that oftentimes
writing from somebody else's
perspective allows me to sort
of figure out that perspective
a little bit more and appreciate
where they're coming from.
And the same is true for
writing from my own perspective.
I was told by a
songwriting teacher
once the best piece
of songwriting advice
I'd ever gotten, which is if
you want to write a good song,
write what you don't want
other people to know about you.
And if you want to
write a great song,
write what you don't want
to know about yourself.
And so writing for me is very
much discovery and exploration.
And whenever my pen hesitates
above the page, and I'm like,
ah, fuck, I absolutely
cannot say that.
I don't want people
to know that about me.
They won't like me.
They won't want to
hang out with me.
That's where I try to start.
So you guys want to
write some tunes?
Write down the one thing
you don't want anybody
to know about you.
And start there.
And I promise you the first
time you do it, it's terrifying.
But if you do it every
day for three months,
it'll just be your
job after a while.
And it'll stop being that scary.
And also you'll realize
that the thing you're
so frightened about, if you
show it to somebody else,
thinking they'll never
speak to you again,
they'll very possibly
say, oh, me too.
And I can't tell you
how good that feels.
To think the thing you think
is the worst thing about you.
And realize that, in
fact, somebody connects
to you because of that.
That's pretty awesome.
ALAN SEALES: And that happens--
that happens after your show,
right?
Like you'll have people
have come up to you
and they'll say like, oh,
yeah, that happened to me too.
BENJAMIN SCHEUER:
Oh, it's great.
The best compliment
I can get is when
somebody says, hey, man, your
story is just like my story.
And then they tell
me the story that has
nothing to do with my story.
[LAUGHTER]
My mother moved to Tennessee
with my dad's canoe.
And like my dad and I
used to canoe together.
And I couldn't work out
why this was happening.
And I think I have an answer.
I think it's not that the stuff
that happens to us is the same.
It's that we pretty
much feel the same way
about the stuff that
does happen to us.
So like we feel alone.
We feel lost.
We feel loved.
We feel understood by
other people, by ourselves.
ALAN SEALES: Especially,
yeah-- in a city like New York,
it's like there's
so many people.
It's so easy to get like lost
up in the shuffle of anonymity.
I mean, do you find the
process of songwriting,
and these people come
up to you, and whatnot,
is it more therapeutic for you
and for them, do you think?
Like just to talk about
things that you're
so afraid to mention publicly.
And then have like
total acceptance.
People like, oh, yeah,
he's a songwriter.
It's cool.
BENJAMIN SCHEUER:
To feel that-- I
mean I really try to do
away with guilt and shame
and feeling bad for
the stuff that I want
and feeling bad for the
stuff that has happened.
And worrying that people
are not going to like me
or are going to think that I'm
strange or think that I look,
or sound, or feel weird.
Because we all feel that way.
And it's just fucking tiring.
It's tiring to not-- to
sort of put up a front.
And New York can very
much be that kind of city.
When I go hear songwriters
who I feel tell their truth,
and they're not showing
how hip they are,
they're just showing
how human they are,
that's what I connect
to as a listener.
I don't need you to be the
coolest person in the world.
But I'd appreciate it if
you're the most honest person.
Because then I feel
like actually we
can have a conversation.
And I can come up to
you and talk to you.
And getting to
play the show for,
for I guess the theater I'm in
right now is about 220 people.
And so it's a really
lovely little space.
ALAN SEALES: The Lynn
Redgrave Theater?
BENJAMIN SCHEUER: Yeah.
It's the Lynn Redgrave Theater.
It's on Bleecker and Lafayette.
And I play six
shows a week there.
I'm off on Mondays and Tuesdays.
And then I play on Wednesday
and Thursday, and then Friday,
and two shows on Saturday,
and a show on Sunday.
And the only thing that
really changes night to night
is the audience.
And different people
react differently.
And I can pretty much
only see the front row
because I'm not
wearing my eye glasses.
It's just like here.
I can see you all
in the front row.
And they become my
cast members inasmuch
as I react to what
they're reacting to.
And I take the pace off of them.
And I'll sing different
things to different people.
And then I'll chill
with people afterwards.
Actually the other day somebody
was sitting in the front row,
just like texting.
And I couldn't--
but in a theater.
And I couldn't tell if they were
like really psyched and really
wanted to text or that just
had never been to the theater
before.
And didn't know
that you're probably
supposed to turn it
off in a theater show.
ALAN SEALES: Right.
So we haven't gotten
to like the real meat
and potatoes of the show,
which I guess, spoiler alert.
Spoiler-- he gets cancer,
which is not a fun thing.
Thanks for laughing.
Yeah.
BENJAMIN SCHEUER: It just
gets better and better.
ALAN SEALES: It gets better.
The show is amazing.
So you get cancer.
You beat cancer.
You talk about all this.
But we'll talk about that
separately in a moment.
But I want to talk about like,
doing it, what did you say,
six times a week, right?
BENJAMIN SCHEUER: Yeah.
ALAN SEALES: So this is a
hugely deep, personal journey
that you are just
putting out there.
You're sharing with these
220 people every night.
I mean do you go to the
same place in your mind
every night to dig up-- I
guess, for lack of anything
better to say-- inspiration for
giving a fresh performance all
the time?
Or does it become tiring
reliving this all the time?
BENJAMIN SCHEUER: Well, it's a
different kind of reliving in
that when I-- so I was diagnosed
with stage four Hodgkin's
lymphoma, all these sweating
through my sheets at night,
and my losing 25 pounds, and
the pain in the left side
of my lower back
when I drank alcohol,
those were all
symptoms of cancer.
And in my case, it was
advanced stage cancer.
And when I was ill, I had
no control over my life.
I had no control at all.
But when I write a song, it
allows me to take a bad thing
and turn it into a good thing.
I can go from feeling
really, really alone
and feel connected directly.
And writing allows
me to be an alchemist
in that I can take
something bad, cancer,
and I can turn it into a
song, which is something good.
And so that to me is
really extraordinary.
I think there's really
a great amount of value
in telling the truth, in
telling the truth in art,
in telling the truth in
art about bad things.
I promise, tell the truth
in art about bad things
and you'll be doing
something good.
And so every night
it feels different
because I get to control cancer.
Cancer is not controlling me.
There's a part in the show
where I sing as cancer.
I take on the sort of character
of cancer and sing as cancer.
And it's totally terrifying
when I first wrote it.
But just like if you do
something enough times,
it becomes strengthening.
Also it's a happy end--
like he lives at the end.
He lives.
It feels lovely to be
able to take bad things
and turn them into good things.
I think it's really a special
thing about song writing.
ALAN SEALES: So you
recently gave a TED Talk
where you discussed exactly
making good things out of bad,
right?
BENJAMIN SCHEUER: Yeah.
I did.
It was TEDxBroadway.
So there's a sort of
Bohemian Rhapsody of cancer
in the middle of the show.
I'll play a little bit
of it for you guys.
So the way I found
out I had cancer
is I was losing all this
weight and feeling really ill.
And I was running through
Grand Central Station
and I slipped and I fell.
It was wintertime.
It was December 2010.
And I spent the next day in
bed, banged up and bruised.
The following day,
I go to my doctor,
who sends me for some X-rays.
And when we sit down to discuss
the results of these X-rays,
he looks serious.
He looked scared.
And he says, listen Ben,
you broke your pubic bone
in the three places.
And the reason you
did is you have
lytic lesions in your pelvis.
I said lytic-- I don't
know what that is.
And he said something's
eating your bones.
So what, like a good kind
of an eating, like a--
[LAUGHTER]
And they send me for more tests.
And the following day, I
sat down with an oncologist.
And I'm expecting him to
say, listen kid, you're fine.
You got holes in your bones.
You got to drink
more chocolate milk.
But instead, he asks me, have
you lost 25 pounds lately?
And I said yeah.
He said have you been sweating
through your sheets at night?
Yeah.
And he said, do you have pain
in the left side of your lower
back when you drink alcohol?
[MUSIC BENJAMIN SCHEUER, "THE
CURE"]
And so I did six
months of chemotherapy,
which is once every two
weeks, 12 doses, from February
to July 2011.
And then--
[MUSIC BENJAMIN SCHEUER, "THE
CURE"]
And when I learned that
I was cured of cancer,
I called my mother
and my brothers,
who had come back from
England to look after me.
And then I wasn't sure
what I was supposed to do.
And I learned something
really interesting,
which is 85% of people who are
successfully cured of cancer
suffer from depression.
And it seems kind of
head scratching at first.
But the thing about
it is you're working
towards this extraordinary
goal, which is not dying.
And you have this crazy
medical treatment.
And everybody is around
you and rooting for you.
And then they tell
your you're cured.
And they're like
OK, you're good.
And you feel as sick as you've
ever felt in your entire life
because you've been pumped
full of poison-- which
is what chemotherapy is-- for
the last, I mean in my case,
it was six months.
But everybody's
like, you're good.
And then they all
kind of go home.
And they're all fine and
they're not worried anymore.
And so I thought,
well, what can I do?
And I started writing.
I started writing about it.
I started telling other
people about what it was like.
And it didn't seem at
the time that maybe there
was value to it.
And sometimes it felt stupid.
And sometimes it felt like
it was kind of pointless.
But I carried on and
I wrote about it.
And I'd really taken the
worst thing in my life
and turned it into
what has become
the best thing in my life.
I made this record
of these songs.
And I started playing the
record around little coffee
shops in New York, just sort
of 10, 20 people at a time.
I made the record with
my band, Escapist Papers.
And the song was
called "The Bridge."
And the way this show
came about at all
is I just didn't
know what I was going
to say between these songs.
And so I wrote it down.
And I figured I'd memorize it.
And I wouldn't tell people
I'd memorized what I was
going to say between the songs.
I wanted to be able to
connect the tunes to one
another better, to be able to
frame each song more clearly.
And so I wrote it down.
And then I had a
script and a score.
And that's basically a musical.
[LAUGHTER]
And so I was invited as
a writer-in-residence
to the Goodspeed Theater.
It's up in Connecticut.
It's a developmental theater.
It's basically a nice
little college campus.
You get a house and a kitchen.
And they pay you to write.
And I told them I was
working on a musical.
It was not a
musical at the time.
It was just these songs.
And living next door
to me were the guys
who wrote another show
called "Urinetown."
It was Mark Hollmann
and Greg Kotis.
These Tony award-winning
writers, really extraordinary,
sort of senior members of
the Broadway community.
And they were
developing a new show
with their director
Sean Daniels.
And so we all became buddies.
And I got invited-- this
was January of 2012.
And then-- is that right?
Yeah.
January of-- no January of 2013.
God, it was just four
years ago-- three years,
two years ago.
Ah-- math.
ALAN SEALES: Maths.
BENJAMIN SCHEUER: I'm
not good at maths.
ALAN SEALES: Maths.
BENJAMIN SCHEUER:
2013, two years ago.
All right.
And I got invited to this
other developmental theater
in April 2013, in Vermont.
And the guy in Vermont
said, man, why don't you
bring a director?
You need another pair of
ears, another pair of eyes
to help you out.
And so I called
the only director
I knew or really ever heard
of, this guy Sean Daniels.
And I asked if he could
recommend a young director
for me to work with?
Because I figured Daniels,
himself, was way--
he was-- way out of my league.
And he very kindly
made three suggestions
for three different directors.
And he said for what it's worth
kid, I'll direct your show.
I like your songs.
You're a cool guy.
And I said, how would that
work, your directing my show?
He's like what do you mean?
I was like-- what?
What do you mean,
what do I mean?
How would it work?
How would you direct my show?
He's like oh, Ben, you
don't have a show, man.
You have like four songs.
And you're probably
going to cut two of them.
[LAUGHTER]
What I'd help you do is make the
thing you really want to make.
I'd help you outline the piece.
And we'll put scenes on white
cards and songs on blue cards.
And I never heard
of this before.
And we'll tell the
story you want to tell.
And I'll tell you
when it's boring.
when it's stupid.
And I'll tell you
when it's confusing.
And this seemed sort of
overly simplistic to me.
But man, I promise you, if you
get rid of boring, and stupid,
and confusing, your
thing is so much better.
Boy, oh boy.
[LAUGHTER]
And so we took the show to
the Edinburgh Fringe Festival.
I applied without telling Sean.
And I was like Sean, we
got a gig for the show.
It's going to be great.
And he said where is it?
And I was like it's in Scotland.
He was like why would
we go to Scotland?
And there are 3,000
pieces of theater
out there in the
Fringe Festival.
It's the biggest theater
festival in the world.
And we went.
And the show was still
called "The Bridge"
at that point, named
after the record.
And so I staged the show,
one chair, three guitars,
no light cues-- no
guitar microphone,
just a vocal microphone.
And I sat in the chair.
And I performed to sort
of 20 people a night.
And then we won the
award for best lyrics
in the whole Fringe Festival.
And then a theater
in London called.
And they said, why don't
you put the show up?
We'd love to do that.
And then a theater in New York
called, the Manhattan Theater
Club, based at City Center.
And they're an amazing theater.
And they sat me down and they
were like we to do your show.
We're going to put a
lot of money behind it.
We're going to do
whatever you want.
The thing is we like working
with directors that we know.
So that's how we're
going to work.
And I said, guys, I
couldn't agree more.
I like working with
directors I know, too.
So we're going to work
with Sean on this piece.
And it wasn't out of some
false idea of loyalty.
He's the right guy for the job.
And so we worked with him.
And we put the show
up in New York.
And it sold out.
And we went to London
and played it there.
And now I'm back at the
Lynn Redgrave Theater.
And it's been a really
extraordinary journey.
It's been really, really cool.
And it just came out of
playing in these little coffee
shops on Cornelius Street.
ALAN SEALES: Did
you imagine the show
would be met with the
critical success that it is?
BENJAMIN SCHEUER: I thought that
maybe some people would dig it.
I was just trying to tell
the truth as hard as I could.
But I try not to
worry about critics
because I mean nobody ever
put up a statue to a critic.
ALAN SEALES: Well, yeah.
So every night you have these
complete strangers there,
coming in night after night.
Are you over, I
guess, impersonal
aspect of playing to strangers?
Do you feel like it's
you and them on stage?
Or is it just you and
you're in your head
and you're telling the story,
reliving it every night?
BENJAMIN SCHEUER: Yeah.
It doesn't seem
impersonal at all.
It never seems impersonal.
So I really try to-- every
night try to tell the story more
simply and more honestly.
Just like as if your best
friend introduced you
to some friend of his
that you never met.
And you're hanging out,
the three of you guys.
And you're telling a
story to that person.
Like that's what it feels like.
That's how I try
to make it feel.
I'm just kind of talking.
I do try to write songs
that feel like I'm
talking when I'm singing.
I'm not a singer really.
I like writing
for other singers.
But when I sing, I try to
write the melody the way
that I would talk because
then it's easier for me.
Like I can't sing
big Broadway notes.
I could never be in anybody
else's musical truly.
Because I'm not an actor
and I'm not a singer.
I can just kind of tell my
story and play a little guitar.
ALAN SEALES: So
going back to cancer.
So you worked with
a photographer.
BENJAMIN SCHEUER: Yeah.
ALAN SEALES: Riya Lerner, right?
Yeah.
So she took your
picture once a week
when you were
getting chemotherapy.
And it turned into this book.
BENJAMIN SCHEUER: Yeah.
I made a book to raise money for
the Leukemia Lymphoma Society.
It's a foundation,
a cancer charity
that's very close to my heart.
And Riya photographed
me once a week.
That was the first photo
she ever took of me.
I was very, very, very ill.
And so on my left pectoral
muscle they put a little tube,
an IV insertion
point right there,
that had a tube, that went
up over my collar bone
and under my ribs and
directly into my heart.
And so that's how
chemotherapy works.
I mean I was so
desperately thin.
But the problem
with New York City
is when you're kind of 25 pounds
underweight and gauntly skinny,
people will come up to you
and be like, oh, my god,
you look amazing.
[LAUGHTER]
Yeah.
And so Riya came and
photographed me once a week
with an old '70s
Rolleiflex camera.
And we documented
this little journey.
And the terrifying
thing was we didn't
know what the end of the
story was going to be.
We didn't know if the last photo
was going to be a gravestone
or whatever.
Or if it was going to be
kind of thumbs up, like yeah.
And so I kept a journal.
And Riya photographed me.
And I learned a lot
from photography
about songwriting
inasmuch as a photo really
should be about one thing.
It should be very simple.
And you should get rid
of all the cluttering
stuff that's in the way.
And it should have
one focal point.
And the focal point
isn't necessarily
what the photo is about.
Meaning you can write a song
about one thing seemingly,
but it's actually
about another thing.
And so I learned a lot
about just art in general
from Riya and from her
extraordinarily keen eye.
I think we've got a
couple more images.
Yeah, that's a pretty
gruesome picture.
That's what
chemotherapy looks like.
There's a needle in
the IV insertion point.
And what's in the
syringe at that moment
is Adriamycin, which is a
very, very potent, very mean
chemotherapeutic drug.
And it's got sort of the
consistency of jello.
It's very thick.
And it burns.
You can feel it like
going into your heart
and burning, which is real
fun, let me tell you, real fun.
And then every
few months I would
get what's called a PET scan.
And a PET scan is how
cancer is tested for.
So cancer is basically a problem
of growth, of reproduction.
Cancer cells are cells
that grow way too fast.
And so when you get a PET
scan, which is a cancer scan,
you're injected with a
radioactive glucose that
attaches itself to your cells.
And then you go
into this machine,
this machine over here.
And the machine sees how fast
the cells are reproducing.
And so it's pretty
amazing technologically.
And one thing that
I sort of discovered
is the first PET scan I
got took about 45 minutes.
The last PET scan I got
took about 20 minutes
just because the computer
technology had improved.
And when I go back now, they
take about five minutes.
ALAN SEALES: Wow.
BENJAMIN SCHEUER: It's
pretty amazing, yeah,
how these technological
advances in data processing
affects all kinds of stuff,
including cancer treatment.
ALAN SEALES: So obviously we
know the end of the story.
BENJAMIN SCHEUER: He lives.
He lives.
By the way that book,
"Between Two Spaces,"
you can check it out at
betweentwospaces.com.
And all the proceeds go to the
Leukemia and Lymphoma Society.
It's a good cause.
ALAN SEALES: It's
a very nice book.
How did you get connected
with her in the first place?
BENJAMIN SCHEUER:
I wrote to a cousin
of mine, who is a photographer.
And I asked her who would
be good for this project?
And she recommended Riya.
And I actually interviewed
some photographers.
And the first photographer
I interviewed came over
and she's like, I'm so sorry
to hear what's going on.
I was like, no, no, no, no.
I don't need your
sympathy, darling.
Like this is an art project.
I've got my friends
and my family.
Thank you.
And I told Riya
about the project.
And she's like this
sounds awesome.
I want to work on this.
We can make something cool.
And I dug her dedication.
And that she kept
impersonal in a way that
ultimately allowed us to be
very, very close friends.
She could kind of
disappear and take a photo,
to the point where
I wouldn't notice.
Like I'd be going about my day.
I'd get into the shower, be
like floating in the bathtub.
And we have a sort of very
fascinating relationship
because the intimacy of being
there, photographing my body.
And what we thought it
was going to be was just
she would take a nude
portrait of me the whole time.
And we'd just see
how the body changed.
But we realized that
actually cancer affects life
in all kinds of ways that
you could never anticipate.
And one of those ways
was that clothing
took on this really
powerful meaning for me.
Because kind of one of the
only things that I could
do on any given day that I had
any control over at all was get
dressed.
And then when you
go to your doctor,
you're in like the
green gown thing.
And you feel sort of half of a
person and you're dehumanized.
And so clothing became control.
It became armor.
And that still
sticks with me today.
ALAN SEALES: So I want
to digress for a second
and talk about your custom,
wonderful custom suit here.
It's a little bit
lopsided, right?
BENJAMIN SCHEUER: Yeah.
It is lopsided because
it's cut to play guitar in.
So this right arm is
cut to go like this.
The left arm is cut
to hold like this.
And the left leg of the
trousers is moving around
because I move this leg,
but not my right leg.
My guitar sits right here.
So it's cut asymmetrically.
And that actually comes from
military and hunting tailoring,
when you cut a jacket
to hold like this.
The British tailors
get it right.
They get it right.
ALAN SEALES: Because they
hunt in Britain, more than
in the US?
BENJAMIN SCHEUER: Well, the
fellow who makes the clothes--
ALAN SEALES: Gun control.
BENJAMIN SCHEUER: The fellow who
makes the clothes for the show
is a guy called Kirk Miller.
And he makes the most fabulous
suits, really, really beautiful
stuff.
And he runs a shop called
Miller's Oath, which
is on Spring and
Greenwich Street,
just down in the
western part of Soho.
And I mean really, really rad,
beautiful, beautiful clothing.
And in the show, I
wear a mic in my hair.
You can't see it.
But just so when I'm
kind of walking around.
As so I wear this bra that
has like microphone wireless
things sitting behind my jacket.
And so the jacket
is cut and the shirt
is cut to sort of
accommodate it at all.
It's all very tricky.
It's all made to look like I'm
sitting in your living room,
but with better lighting design.
ALAN SEALES: And six guitars.
BENJAMIN SCHEUER: Yeah.
Absolutely.
ALAN SEALES: Why six guitars?
I mean you've got two here.
You've only played
one of them so far.
BENJAMIN SCHEUER: Yeah.
ALAN SEALES: Obviously,
we got more songs to come.
But why six?
BENJAMIN SCHEUER:
I play six guitars
because a lot of the songs
require different tunings.
And what I mean by
different tunings
is I tune the guitar
to a different chord.
And this one right here
is tuned C, G, D, G, C, E.
And having different
chords allow
for different textures,
different tonalities,
different voicings.
This guitar to my left that
I'll play in a little bit,
I play two songs in
the show with it.
This one is tuned to D, A, D, D,
A, D. And so you can do stuff.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
We were talking earlier and you
asked me about the guitar part
in that first song
"Cookie-tin Banjo"
and why do I have six guitars?
Well, I like to try
and use each guitar
as sort of a few different
instruments at once.
In the "Cookie-tin
Banjo," the melody goes--
[MUSIC PLAYING]
And the baseline goes--
And so together
that sounds like--
[MUSIC PLAYING]
And if you do that
and you put chords
in between the bass and the
melody, it sounds like this.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
And there's an electric guitar
for a couple of the songs
that I play as an
angry teenager.
It's a '72 Goldtop Les Paul.
It's a really rad guitar.
There's a guitar that plays
the role of dad's old guitar.
And that's a 1929 Martin O-18.
This one over here
is a Froggy Bottom.
They're made in Vermont.
And they build about
100 guitars a year.
And this one was built for me.
My brothers got it for me
as a 30th birthday present.
It's Adirondack spruce up
top, walnut back and sides.
And I don't know-- you
probably can't see.
But there's a little
watercolor of a lion painted
on the heel of the neck there.
It's pretty awesome.
ALAN SEALES: So
I expect everyone
to be able to play because he
gave you such direct lessons.
So do you ever talk
to your ex-girlfriend
about any of this?
BENJAMIN SCHEUER: Julia.
Do I talk to Julia?
Well, she plays a pretty
prominent role in the show.
And she did write to me when
the show opened in New York
last summer at the
Manhattan Theater Club
to wish me well and
congratulations,
which was very cool of her.
Beyond that, no, we don't talk.
ALAN SEALES: What
about your family,
are they still in London?
BENJAMIN SCHEUER:
They are in London.
Actually Simon, my
brother Simon was in town.
And he came to see "The
Lion" a couple weeks ago,
the same night that Bruce
Willis came to see it.
And Bruce took me and Simon
out to get sushi at Nobu.
It was very cool.
And he was telling me he's
about to do a Broadway
play in the fall.
And so we were just
kind of talking
about the intimacy of acting
in a really small room.
But at the end of this
show, ultimately he
decided that he was going
to come play the character
Ben in my musical.
And I decided I was going to
go be an international action
superhero.
[LAUGHTER]
ALAN SEALES: How is
that working out so far?
BENJAMIN SCHEUER:
I got the boots.
[LAUGHTER]
ALAN SEALES: So your
fingers-- I mean
I just love watching you play.
I'm talking way less than
I should as a moderator.
But I just love when
your fingers just start
moving at the speed of light.
BENJAMIN SCHEUER: Thank you.
ALAN SEALES: Did that come
about sort of naturally
as you developed your own style?
Or were you ever trying
to emulate like the power
chords on the radio?
And you're like, ah, this
is just really boring,
degern, degern, degern.
BENJAMIN SCHEUER: Yeah.
I wanted to learn to play
like Eddie Van Halen.
ALAN SEALES: Oh, really.
BENJAMIN SCHEUER: Oh, yeah.
Absolutely.
And so I practiced six
to eight hours a day
to learn to do all the acrobatic
and crazy technical stuff
for the guitar.
I really wanted to see what
the guitar was capable of.
And it was cool to do all
that stuff technically.
But I came to the
horrifying conclusion
that Eddie Van Halen already
plays like Eddie Van Halen.
And he's pretty good at it.
So if I was going to
figure out how to play,
I'd better learn
to play like myself
and figure out what
that actually is.
I mean in a really
technical way,
I do a lot of hybrid picking.
Meaning I hold a guitar
pick between my thumb
and my first finger.
And then these other
three fingers just kind of
have a mind of their own.
They're doing other
stuff as I'm doing it.
So that's why you can
play a bass, and a melody,
and chords in between.
These will be the ones
playing chords, these fingers.
Pinky is playing the melody.
And my pick is playing the bass.
And so I like to get
different sounds.
I mean there's one little
bit of a Van Haleny trick
in the show at the very end.
It sounds like this.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
And it sounds really,
really complicated.
I promise you it's not actually.
It's really not.
But that's a little
bit of the Van Halen
influence coming into my
acoustic guitar playing.
ALAN SEALES: So do you end
up listening and liking
more blue grassy, folk
music sort of stuff?
And what do you listen
to in your spare time?
BENJAMIN SCHEUER: I listen
to a lot of hip hop.
Yeah.
ALAN SEALES: I'm going to let
that sink in for a second.
BENJAMIN SCHEUER: I mean
storytelling is really
what I dig.
I dig a compelling story and
Tupac Shakur, Marshall Mathers,
OutKast, Nas.
Marshall Mathers is
Eminem, of course.
Biggie, Big Pun.
I'm a big fan of his record,
"Capital Punishment" in 1996.
It's a great record.
Yeah.
And these guys are taking
what really is lyrically
the most advanced-- it's the
most advanced kind of lyricism.
And here's the thing.
So the best piece of musical
theater up right now--
and if you haven't heard
of it, you absolutely will.
Paul McCartney was
there last night--
is "Hamilton." "Hamilton"
was written by a guy called
Lin-Manuel Miranda.
And it's about
Alexander Hamilton.
And it is a hip hop show.
And it's not trying
to sort of falsely
squeeze hip hop onto Broadway.
He is a rapper and
he is a writer.
And he is one of the
best guys around.
And he wrote a show that's
completely a game changer,
just the way Leonard
Bernstein thought, well,
why don't we take
real orchestral music
and put it on stage?
And he wrote "West Side Story."
And everyone was
like, oh, OK, right.
You've changed the way
musical theater works.
Lin-Manuel has on
the same thing.
And though my stuff, it
absolutely sounds folky
and sounds blue grassy,
that's just because I
play the acoustic guitar.
But in actuality to me, hip hop
is much more the thing that I'm
really, really interested in.
Because these guys are
doing-- guys and girls--
are doing things that I aspire
to do, that I would love to do.
I would love to tell these
dense and complex stories.
I mean "Hamilton" is 2
hours and 45 minutes.
And there's not a wasted
syllable in that show.
Every syllable is extraordinary.
I mean go.
Go see it if you can.
It's amazing.
And I listen to a lot of jazz,
Oscar Peterson, the pianist.
The musicals I do dig,
I dig Frank Loesser,
who wrote "Guys and Dolls."
That's absolutely
my favorite show.
Actually before "The Lion,"
the sort of preshow music,
is Miles Davis and
his quintet playing
songs from "Guys and Dolls."
And I wonder how many
people have caught that.
But I get to warm up
in my dressing room
to "If I Were a Bell."
It's a wonderful melody.
It's wonderful lyric.
I mean those melodies are
so strong that when you just
hear the melody, you
hear the words too.
And that's the kind of things
that I'd like to write.
I'd really like to
write a melody that's
so strong that you
can hear the words.
Or write a lyric so strong
that you automatically
hear the melody.
ALAN SEALES: Well, you have.
After the show and during
warm-ups and everything this
morning, I've have "Cookie-tin
Banjo" in head nonstop.
Like even as I'm sitting
here listening to you talk,
I have "Cookie-tin Banjo"
going through my head.
After you played
the other stuff,
I still go back to
"Cookie-tin Banjo."
BENJAMIN SCHEUER: It's
a sticky little melody.
ALAN SEALES: It is.
It is.
I really like it.
So we've talked about the
music, the song writing,
and the lyrics, and everything.
So now, we've got the show.
You've got music videos, too.
BENJAMIN SCHEUER: Yeah.
I'm making a record right now
called "Songs From The Lion."
So musical theater has
been doing it backwards.
Musical theater makes recordings
of the shows as souvenirs
to sell in the lobby.
And this is so stupid to me.
Like if you make a record,
don't make a souvenir.
Make a piece of art.
And your show is not
to sell your record.
I mean, I'm playing
to 200 people a night.
What am I going
to sell, like 150?
10 maybe?
Your record is to
sell your show.
You put out a record, you should
try and sell a million copies.
And if you ask any 10-year-old
how do you listen to music,
they'll tell you YouTube.
And so put out a single.
Put out as many
singles as you can.
And make music videos for them.
And so I've made a music
video for the song "Cookie-tin
Banjo."
And it's an animated video.
It has seemingly nothing
to do with the show.
But to me, it's the same story.
And then I made a video
for the song, "The Lion."
And I made these both with a
fellow called Peter Baynton.
And "The Lion," it premiered
at the Annecy Film Festival.
Annecy is a town in the
north of France, just south
of Switzerland.
And it's the biggest animated
festival in the world.
And we made a little video
for just over $10,000.
And it was playing at Annecy
alongside videos from Bjork.
And Thom Yorke from
Radiohead had a video.
I mean some really
amazing artists,
who I really, really admire.
And I was out there
for a couple days
and I didn't stay until the end.
I went back to London
to see my family.
And I got a call from Peter
Baynton, the director/animator.
And he's like, hey, man, I just
want to let you know we won.
And I was like we won what?
And he said, we won the
best commissioned film
in the festival for "The Lion."
And I could not believe it.
And so Pete and I are making
a third video right now,
third animated video.
And we're also making a film
video and one for the song
"Cure," the cancery one that I
played earlier-- cancery one,
yea.
ALAN SEALES: Did you film
during the process too?
BENJAMIN SCHEUER: No.
There's no video footage.
I don't believe so.
Ah, that would've
been a good idea.
Eh.
ALAN SEALES: Next time.
Don't relive it.
So we've got "The
Lion" video now.
It's queued up.
That's why the
screen went black.
So we would like
to have you play
it live while the video's
going in the background.
BENJAMIN SCHEUER: Yeah.
Absolutely.
And before I play, I just
want to say thank to you
guys for listening
to me talk and sing.
And thank you very
much for having me.
[APPLAUSE, CHEERS]
Here's "The Lion," friends.
[MUSIC BENJAMIN SCHEUER, "THE
LION"]
[APPLAUSE, CHEERS]
ALAN SEALES: Nice.
So we've got microphones
in each aisle.
We've got some tickets
to give away to those
of you who may have questions.
If you have questions,
please go there now.
This has been
absolutely wonderful.
What was the process like
making the animated video
in the first place?
Do you have a lot
of input into that?
BENJAMIN SCHEUER:
Well, Peter is a-- he
went to Cambridge in England.
And he studied architecture
and oil painting
because he likes making
three-dimensional things
in two dimensions.
And eventually, he
realized, you know
what, I think actually I'm
supposed to be an animator.
I want to tell stories, big
three-dimensional stories
in two dimensions.
And so we had a mutual
friend who connected us.
And I'd finished
recording that song,
"The Lion" on the
record "The Bridge"
with Escapist Papers, my band.
And so I called my
friend Alex and I said,
I'm looking to
animate this video.
And there's so many words in it.
And I really want to
do it pretty literally.
Do you know any animators?
And he said, yeah,
you should talk
to my friend Peter Baynton.
And so I went to meet Pete.
I'd sent him the
song ahead of time.
And he turned up at our
meeting with this cardboard
guy he'd made with an Exacto
knife and a piece of cardboard.
And he said, what about
him as the main character?
ALAN SEALES: It looks just me.
BENJAMIN SCHEUER: Yeah.
And I just kind of burst
into tears, I was so moved.
And Pete and I talked.
It took us about nine
months to make the video.
And actually I met his mom at
the British Animation Awards,
where Pete took home
the award for "The Lion"
for public choice
for best music video.
And Pete's mom said, I thought
that-- Peter was at home.
And the kitchen floor
was covered in cardboard.
And I didn't know
what was going on.
And Pete, I really just
let him do his thing.
He sent me an
animatic initially.
And what an animatic
is, it's basically
a slide show to the song,
which is kind of drawings
of how the story would work.
And one thing that was
really important to Peter
was character.
In the very beginning
of the video,
there's a table with
all the pictures
of all the lions in the family.
And what's
fascinating about that
is Peter followed every
single one of those characters
on a journey through the song.
There's no character
that doesn't
have a journey in the song.
And so it was very much about
telling everybody's story very
specifically and being
really true to that.
And there's no wasted time.
Similar to the way Riya,
the photographer, works.
Peter works the same way.
And I love, man, I
loved working with him.
And I don't have to
do a lot with Pete.
I send him a song, and
I send him my ideas,
and I let him get on with it.
And he'll come back and say,
this is what we're doing.
And it's awesome.
And I hope to-- we're going
to make two more videos.
And one day, I want to make an
animated feature film with him.
We've made these little movies
for a little bit of money.
One day, I want to go bother
Pixar and go get $10 million
and make a real movie.
I mean he's going to be
an extraordinary person
to do that with.
Radish Pictures is his company.
Mark my words, in 10
years, Radish Pictures,
they'll be fighting you
guys for real estate.
ALAN SEALES: Oh, yeah, question?
AUDIENCE: Hey, Ben.
BENJAMIN SCHEUER: Hey.
AUDIENCE: Kevin.
I've been a fan of yours
since you played guitar
in the production of "Tommy"
that I produced at Harvard.
BENJAMIN SCHEUER: No kidding.
Hey, man.
AUDIENCE: Best
undergraduate production
of "Tommy" guitar player ever.
BENJAMIN SCHEUER:
Well, thank you.
That was really fun.
AUDIENCE: It was awesome.
It was great.
Yeah.
It was like 14 years ago.
So like obviously, you're
a great songwriter.
And 50 years ago, you might
be on like a Stephen Sondheim
path, where you
just write musicals
and they start in Boston.
And then they go to Broadway.
Other than "Hamilton,"
I don't know
if there are many like original
musicals coming to Broadway.
So what does the career look
like for someone who wants
to be a Broadway songwriter?
And given like most of the
Broadway theaters right
now are Disney or
movie adaptations,
what are the plans
for your career?
BENJAMIN SCHEUER:
Well, I wholeheartedly
believe that making
records and making theater
are not in opposition
to one another.
They're, in fact,
the same thing.
And that if you want to
write a show that you want
to be successful, there's
so many tools that
can reach beyond the
theater to get audiences
that don't go to the theater.
I mean the people who come
to see "The Lion," yeah,
it's a theater audience.
But it's also kids
who just hang out
at Rockwood Music Hall,
kids who dig pop music
or who dig folk music.
And so I think that if
you're writing a show,
release your singles.
And if they don't work
as singles, rewrite them.
And if then they
don't work, then
probably your show
isn't going to work
in the contemporary era.
And if your songs are
compelling enough,
then people don't even
know they're from a show.
It doesn't matter.
People don't need to see the
"Cookie-tin Banjo" video.
If they like it, they don't need
to know it's from "The Lion."
I mean it's a humble video.
It's only been seen 125,000
times, which is nothing
in sort of big YouTube terms.
But it's way more than people
who have seen the show.
There's only 200
seats in the theater.
So I would advise any songwriter
who's writing for the stage--
and I do, in my group
of writer friends.
And it's really a huge
community here in New York.
I mean Sam Willmott is
an amazing songwriter.
Jean Rose, an
amazing songwriter.
Shaina Taub is an
These people are really
putting on creative, different
sounding, excellent theater.
I advise them to write
about themselves.
Because man, if you can't
write about yourself,
like good luck writing
about somebody else.
Good luck telling
somebody else's truth
if you have a hard
time telling your own.
Beyond that, yeah, I think
thinking of different ways
to do theater.
I mean different venues.
Anything goes.
I mean I was told that doing
a one-person autobiographical
musical was a terrible idea.
And I was like, OK, cool.
Maybe no one will like it.
But that's what I
feel like doing.
And I don't think
there really are rules.
And I think the young
producers, some of whom
are in this room
today, they dig that.
And they'll help
you make your thing.
If you believe wholeheartedly,
and you put together
a good team of people,
and you have a cool story
to tell in a cool way,
like it'll totally work.
That's what I think.
AUDIENCE: And I
work on YouTube now.
So I'll see what I can do about
getting that play count up.
BENJAMIN SCHEUER: Great man.
Thank you very much.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
BENJAMIN SCHEUER: Hey.
AUDIENCE: You talked
about-- I mean
a lot of like what
you talked about
has come from like your
personal experience
and your personal story.
You also talked about
the technical skills
that you sought out to learn.
So I was curious to know
how much of like what you're
bringing to the table as
far as like your actual--
the musical skills
and the writing
skills came from a school
setting versus self-taught?
BENJAMIN SCHEUER: Well, I have a
degree in English from Harvard.
And I spent a lot of time
reading and performing
in theater and
studying structure,
studying three-act structure.
And so very, very quickly,
classical three-act structures.
The first act is here
is your protagonist.
Here is what they want.
The second act is here's
why you can't have it
and how they go off on their
journey to try to get it.
And the third act is they get
it and they go home happy.
That's a comedy.
They don't get it and they die.
That's a tragedy.
Or they realize that they
actually really wanted
something else all along, and
they get that other thing,
and they kind of change
their point of view.
And that's a drama.
This has been going
on for 10,000 years,
however long stories
have been told.
And the thing about that
that I've taken away
is I try to incorporate that
three-act structure that I've
learned by studying
theater and literature
into every single
song, into each song.
And so, yeah, it's
very technical.
"The Lion's" structure, the
piece of theater structure,
is very much based on
Joseph Campbell, who's
a 20th-century
American historian who
codified the hero's journey.
He was like, OK, what
do Buddha, and Jesus,
and Moses, and Odysseus
all have in common?
How are their stories similar?
And he kind of worked out that
they all follow pretty much
a similar trajectory.
And so structurally,
yeah, I really
try to be very technical.
Because the closer I stay to
the technical structuralism,
the farther I can go in
telling my version of that.
And I've been very lucky to
study at the Johnny Mercer
songwriting workshop.
It's one week long.
It's hosted at
Northwestern University.
And here's the way it works.
You apply, if you're
18 to 30 years old.
And you send in three tunes.
And if you get in, they
buy you a plane ticket,
and they give you
a bunch of money,
and they bring you to
Northwestern for a week.
And you just write with
three master teachers.
Andrew Lippa is a
fabulous writer.
He's got "Big Fish,"
and "Addam's Family,"
and "I Am Harvey
Milk," the oratorio.
Craig Carnelia is
another songwriter.
Lari White is
another songwriter,
the woman who told me if you
want to write a great song,
if you want to
write a good song.
And I just got paid to write.
It was the first
time anybody had ever
said you should do that.
This is a job.
And there are no assignments.
But you go and you
write whatever you want.
And then these three
master teachers
will say-- you'll play a tune.
And they'll say, oh, you know
the second verse is actually
similar to this Dylan song that
maybe you haven't checked out.
Or did you see Stephen
Sondheim's version of this song
that you're doing?
This is a I'm sad
you left song, or a
I want you to love me song,
or a I want to change song.
I mean it's all pretty similar.
We're writing the same songs
again, and again, and again.
It goes back to what we
were talking about earlier.
It's not that our
stories are the same.
But we feel the
same way about it.
And it was extraordinary
to be able to work
with these writers, these
professional writers,
and to meet other young writers
who had similar ambitions.
And so to be able to be part
of a community of songwriters
is one of the most
valuable things.
Because we'll talk about
how rhyme can be helpful,
how enjambment can be helpful,
how setting up an expectation
and then not fulfilling it
in a song can be helpful.
And these are all
the technical tools.
And I very much believe
that learn the technique
as much as you can.
And then use it in support
of, rather than in place of,
what you want to say.
AUDIENCE: All right.
ALAN SEALES: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: I have
a simple question.
What keeps you moving every
day, like what you keep doing?
And what's the motivation?
Where are you getting it from?
BENJAMIN SCHEUER: I get a lot of
motivation from the audiences.
And some days I wake
up and I'm like, man,
I do not want to
go to the theater.
I'm tired.
And it's snowing outside.
I'm like, I'm comfy in bed.
And then I go do a show.
And mean I met a young kid who
was 17 years old the other day,
who's studying-- or 18 I guess.
He's at NYU.
And he's studying
songwriting and acting.
And he said, man, you're
doing what I want to do.
That's inspiring
that I don't know
how I could write songs about
myself and it could be a job.
But you're doing that.
And that makes me want
to get out of bed.
And I was like, OK, well,
that's pretty beautiful.
I'm a pretty happy guy.
I get to play guitar for a
job and wear red clothes.
[LAUGHTER]
It's pretty awesome.
I love going to the
recording studio.
I love working with Geoff
Kraly, who's my record producer.
We've worked together for years.
And we have the best time.
We get to play with microphones,
and play with words,
and play with melodies.
And also I get to play
with some of the people
I've always dreamed
about working with.
That's one of the
coolest things.
ALAN SEALES: Like Bruce Willis.
BENJAMIN SCHEUER:
Like Bruce Willis.
Well, in terms of the record
that I'm making for the show,
I'm not just making a record
with guitar and vocals.
That's how it is in the show.
But on the record, I
was like, all right,
well who are the people I've
always wanted to work with?
And there's this one tune in the
show, its on electric guitar.
It's kind of a Nine
Inch Nails thing.
And I was like, why don't we
just hire Nine Inch Nails?
They're just guys.
You can call them.
And so we called Josh
Freese, who plays drums
in Nine Inch Nails, and with
Sting, and with Guns and Roses,
and we said come play
on the record, man.
And he sure, why not?
And so that's incredibly
exciting to me.
So something that
really motivates me
is working with people
who are better than I am.
If I can keep doing that,
I'll be a happy guy.
ALAN SEALES: Well, thank
you so much for coming out.
That was wonderful.
[APPLAUSE]
So we've got one more song
you're going to give us,
to close out, that's not
so sad, not so cancery.
So yeah, before you start,
I want to give you a plug.
Everyone visit
thelionmusical.com,
visit Benjamin online,
benjaminscheuer.com.
The show is great.
It's phenomenal.
I can't go on-- I can go on
and on about how wonderful it
and just how touching it is.
So I'm going to
get off the stage,
give you your final moment.
BENJAMIN SCHEUER:
Thank you very much.
ALAN SEALES: Please.
Thank you for coming.
[APPLAUSE]
BENJAMIN SCHEUER:
Here's a happy song.
[MUSIC BENJAMIN SCHEUER, "HELLO
JEMIMA"]
[APPLAUSE, CHEERS]